let's bring in Pat 40 who joins us on
the program good morning Pat how are you
hey I'm all right Dan happy to be on
with the medical experts today now have
you heard anything about the pac-12 and
the Big Ten with what I just mentioned
about are they going to be just
conference only games so there's no real
travel outside what they normally do
well I mean I think it's definitely
under consideration and that may even be
a leaning at this point but I don't
think it's a done deal by any stretch
you know I think everybody's going to at
least try to take this to July first
with hopes of a whole season and then
maybe you're scaling back from there you
know I think that that people will wait
as long as they can before they start
stripping down anything that that
they're hoping to do but is it on the
table yeah I believe both those options
are definitely on the table when you
tweet it out is the first cancel in
college football game a sign of what's
to come
what do you mean by that well yeah the
HBCU games from Memphis between Jackson
State and Tennessee States
September 12th that's been called off
they said they're two Tobit 19 concerns
and problems so is that going to be the
first of many and are we going to see
games dropping by the wayside and I
think maybe especially a neutral site
kind of games where you're you're not
only importing both teams you're
importing both fan bases could be
particularly problematic and could be
hard to sell tickets for if if you're
allowed to have fans even in the stadium
so you know I think that those kind of
games especially could be susceptible to
being called off we'll see you know I
mean everybody wants to have the games
they're profitable they TV the inventory
for sure but you know if the any games
are going to go those to be the first
one yeah but SEC is full steam ahead how
is that well we'll say you can they're
saying it and so far they're playing it
you know I mean they think they've got
players on campus and voluntary workouts
are going on and there have been
positive tests you know almost everybody
is reporting that they're having some
and you know numbers up to I think it's
eight an Arkansas state
and you know similar four-five-six
elsewhere the question I think then is
okay what's the appetite how many is too
many how many of them are serious cases
how many you know their hospitalizations
involved or you know are they
life-threatening or are these just you
know well I don't feel very well for two
or three days and then I'm okay you know
I think that there's just gonna have to
be a lot of calibration this is probably
school by school on what the appetite is
for for how many cases you can handle
and how many serious they shoot the beer
how would you describe Mike Gundy job
status today questionable you know I
think that it's it's been a very bad
week for him and the revelations
yesterday from Alfred Williams by Sharon
sharp about you know using racial slurs
to war players only throws more logs on
the fire
you know Gundy came out and eventually
fell on his sword with a very scripted
apology that came across rather woodenly
on video but then he did some more video
apparently reveals PN it was maybe a
little bit more candid he is he's owning
his mistakes and regarding the t-shirt
we'll see what he says about the
nineteen eighty nine instead he denied
it at a time but there were multiple
Colorado players who said it did happen
and you know I just talked about how
much how much of an appetite you have
for things well how much does Oklahoma
State want to put up with for this guy
well also here's the key seven and six
and eight and five the last two years
that can put you in a tenuous situation
if you have this baggage with you and
you can't read a statement if you really
want people to feel like this hurts you
and it bothers you and you understand
you know that anybody can write a script
for you and this had to come from the
heart if I'm a player I'm not buying
into any of this from my gun dick not at
all and I you know I don't think he's
you know maybe he's built up enough
house credit to stay and survive this
but going seven and six and eight and
five that'll put you in a tenuous
situation seventy six eight and five
- and thirteen live sperm against
Oklahoma that doesn't help either no
yeah things are trending their own way
fur coach mullet do you think he'll be
fired partner do you think he'll be
fired I you know I don't know I I mean
I'm look I'm surprised he still has his
job given some of the things he's done
there so you wouldn't put it past me
that he keeps it especially given the
fact that they have a weak athletic
director and the administration of the
school doesn't seem overly motivated or
have the stomach to fight Mike Gundy
he's pretty popular with the fan base -
yeah as you said some declining returns
but I you know I I would say at this
point he's gonna keep his job but it
would shock me if he did I just saw
where as ions lawsuit is now going to be
taken out of Florida now it's basically
a home court advantage in North Carolina
where are we headed with this lawsuit
was ion and the impact it could have on
Duke basketball yeah I think Sian and
Duke are both gonna skate here probably
as he said that being thrown out of
Florida and in the North Carolina's
another advantage to given this you know
I think at worst case they settled in
this thing goes away that he's never
going to get deposed he's never going to
have to answer those questions about
what he received to go to do for while
he was at Duke but you know I think that
his hope is that this whole thing is
just going to continue to be legal
victories for him and defeats Virgina
Ford and eventually she'll just have to
go away without a settlement but I think
at worst case you will settle if I would
have told you a couple of years ago Zion
would you be more surprised ion got paid
or he didn't get paid going to college I
would always be more surprised he didn't
know that yeah Kevin since September
2017 when the federal investigation blew
up and confirmed everything we thought
was going on I I'm surprised that any
good player goes to school for free he's
pad forty Sports Illustrated senior
college sports writer UNLV needs a new
nicknamed new mascot now is that right I
well yeah they took down their rebel
statue and I think there's going to be
discussions about whether they will
still be called the rebels and I mean
let's be frank you Nov I don't even
think Las Vegas was a city at the time
of the Civil War so it's not like they
were part and parcel of the southern
heritage or the Confederacy but they did
choose the nickname rebels they chose a
kind of old-timey southern potentially
looking mascot guy and those are
problematic these days and if you want
to just you know if if you're not sure
and you want to err on the side of let's
not get ourselves into further you know
political hot water here let's go ahead
and change it I mean I don't think you
know rebels is some sort of cherished
thing at UNLV the bigger issue will then
be what happens at Ole Miss yeah which
is also the rebels and has quite the
tortured racial history where we headed
do you think with Washington in the NFL
I know Mike Florio has talked about this
as kind of an initiative a grassroots
you know and the climate the timing is
right for this but could you see that
happening where that owner caves in and
changes the nickname I think so yeah I
mean I think it's just a tougher and
tougher position to maintain as you said
that this was already an unpopular
nickname in the current climate there's
less and less justification for it and I
think you just get to the point of why
do you want to keep fighting that fight
or why do you want to keep alienating
parts of your fan base with that and I
think you know you look at the Utah Utes
the Florida State Seminoles and a lot of
people with Native American mascots and
nicknames and I think all of them are
under renewed pressure to do something
about it
it's great to talk to you and appreciate
you making some time for us today safe
travels Pat thank you Dan appreciate it
good here for you
that's bad for tease Sports Illustrated
senior college sports writer